バンカ
ラジオ俺の名前は天才小学生や今日は職業
見学で幼稚園に来
たそれでは読み聞かせの時間です腹ペコ
青虫ご覧の通りエたちは全く言うことを
聞きませんほらみんな聞い
てなんで大人の言うことが聞けない
の私今日でお仕事やめますええちょっと
それはなんでおの言うこと聞けない
の今までありがとうございまし
た困ったなどこかで先生やってくれる人
[音楽]
はやすお前も先生の大変さを勉強するいい
機会だ延長先生やすが喜んで引き受ける
そうです頼むよやす君ちょちょっと待っ
て新しくこのクラスの宣伝になったや
ですこいつら全員天才になる素質はある
みたいだなそれではみんなに聞かせ
をしませんえ今日はハッキングについて
学んでいこうハッキング俺が君たちを天才
にして
やるうわ
まずは手始めに公共電波をジャックし
[音楽]
ますゴシゴシゴシゴシそる潜在小学生
ゴシゴシゴシゴシそる潜在小学
生それじゃあみんなもやって
[音楽]
みようと細小学生なんで大人の言うことが
聞けないのなんでで大人なんで大人の言う
こと
でちょっとお前らやりすぎだ
やめろ次はロケットランチャーを使うよあ
あんなところに泥棒がいた試しに打って
みよう
うわーそれじゃああのマ狙って打ってみて
[音楽]
ありキャプルカッたぞ
おい誰に当ててん
[音楽]
だ次はワップの練習だ見て
てじゃー
おおそれじゃみんなもやってみようワープ
おおみんなうまいじゃんかあれ1人足り
ないえここどこここどこどこどこどい
トイレいやーなんで女子トに男子がいるの
ぎーおかだ
うわー誰がおかより
なさい次は高速クラフトの授業
ですでき
たでき
[音楽]
たできた
ええマニ
っちゃだめだ
よどれどれうまくやってるか
[音楽]
なすごい楽しそうで何より
だ口喧嘩で人を言まかした時に使う言葉
せーのハパせーのハロパせーのハロパせー
のパ
ほらま帰るわよはいワえどこ行った
どこさすが子供は物覚えが早い
ななおちゃん何作ってる
のできたゴキブ
行け行け行け行け行け行け行け行け行け
あんた宿題やりなさいゲームは募集よ
ワップ行け行け行け行けけけけけけけけけ
ワープけけけけけけけけ
けけけ
ワープらどこ行った
のルイくパソコン見て何してるの
ハッキング
何してる
のこれをこうしてこうゴムテップはねこう
やって使うのよおらこんなのただの女
じゃんあんた何よそれうつから見てて見て
てじゃないわやめ
なさいアインシュタインは相対性理論を
確立した人物なんだちなみにこんな顔
ね新曲アインシュタイン少年が公開された
よ歌もダンスも覚えられるようにみんな
何十回何百回も聞いて
ねい
[拍手]
でうタの教育はどうなってるんですかはい
はい今すぐ対処してくれないと教育委員会
に訴えますよはいはい
延長お様方からのクレムが止まりません助
先生の問題どうしましょうさすがにこれ
以上続けてもらうわけにはかない
な助先生残念なお知らせです何ですか君の
授業に対してたくさんのクレームが来て
ます申し訳ないが首だそうですか何が
おかしいんだ首になるのはあなたの方です
延長
先生なんだ
[音楽]
やめろ日本全国の皆さんごげよ僕天才です
からでおなみ神やです突然ですか皆さん
子供にとって1番大切なことって何だと
思いますか
それは教育ですですが今の日本の教育は
腐っていますそこで我々は革命を起こす
ことにしましたこれは日本の教育機関に
対する先告ですそれで
はなんて
[音楽]
ことんをしてで進むと思うなよ
うるさい助けて
ママ
ほらアネスのエジたち君たちは完全に放置
されている大人しく出てきなさいお前ら
準備はいいな僕天才ですから行け
コブだは
[音楽]
一コマ高速の時間だいやそれにしても子供
を殴り日が来るとな俺もやりたかねえんだ
よでき
たいやでもなあ殴るのはなこんな
う
暗い嘘だよんほらおもちゃを置いて降参し
なさい
うわほら手を
あげろほら本当にいつ
ぞうわあ
ワープどうなってん
ださすが天才エンジ大人たちと対当に
やり合ってる子供だからって容赦するなワ
もう作らせない
ぞ
かかほこれでとめだ巨大ミサイル
発ロケットランチャーで
撃てハッキングのミサイルの度を変えろ
できないよ
あえ
こりゃまずい
ぞスーパー
マリア先生っ
[音楽]
みんな無事か子供相手に音あげないことし
てしまってすまなかっただからその考えが
ダメなんだよ大人と子供は当大人は子供を
教育してるようで自分もまた教育されてる
んだそんな考え今までにはなかったあそれ
じゃあこんなのはどう
[音楽]
だそれじゃあみんなゴリラの絵を描いてね
できまし
た上手にできたねよちよち
[音楽]
めでたし
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしくはチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録JA